[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com let's talk about Donald
Trump's commandeering of American
television to propagandize about the
border wall over which he shut down the
government last night
we will talk about the content of this
address I mentioned yesterday during a
live stream that I did covering this and
and also earlier on yesterday's show
that there are really kind of three
issues here number one is is there
actually an undocumented immigration
crisis I laid out the case yesterday for
why there is not secondly if there were
such an immigration crisis would the
wall that Donald Trump is proposing be
the solution to that crisis I explained
why it would not and then issue number
three layer number three was would a
presidential address of this type in
primetime on television be the right
place for overt political lobbying for
the policy that Donald Trump wants and I
also made the case that it was not and
the the speech in the end was nine
minutes long half just lies at a rate
that we maybe have not seen previously
during a Trump speech the other half
just anecdotal appeals to emotion and
I'm not gonna focus too too much on
those because I think our audience
mostly understands that you don't make
policy based on anecdotal appeals to
emotion but we should talk about the
lies that we're told because that
actually is important but the primary
takeaway is this address never should
have happened it was purely political it
was a lobbying speech I actually would
be okay with a presidential address in
primetime on all TV networks for
lobbying the public about a real
emergency or a crisis right we have a
climate change emergency on our planet
if we had a president say I'm going to
address the American people because of
the crisis that is climate change in
what we're doing to our planet that
would actually make sense because it's
real
real crisis could be we've got a
president who's an accused serial sex
assault er with at least one child
accuser that is more of a crisis than
the crisis of undocumented immigrants
coming over the us-mexico border so
there are many ways in which I would
support a president saying I need to
address the nation tonight this is not
one of them and most of the lies that
Trump told were told up front I'll go
through a few of them I'm not gonna play
the nine minute thing because it's only
9 minutes and it's very easy to find
I'll focus just on analyzing the lies
that were told Donald Trump called this
he sort of opened this thing yesterday
calling it a growing crisis and as I've
already outlined it's not a crisis at
all but it's definitely not growing
there's no evidence that this is a
growing problem border crossings are
lower and lower and lower each year
dating all the way back to the year 2000
there has been an increase in the last
few months but that's mostly asylum
seekers who are people going through the
correct legal process to ask for asylum
in the United States Donald Trump said
we don't have any way of returning
people to where they came from quickly
quickly is subjective but we do have a
mechanism for doing that however the
fact that Trump has shut down government
is actually what's slowing that process
down making it so that immigration
hearings have slowed down to an absolute
halt Trump arguing that we are really
hurt economically that this is a strain
on resources undocumented immigrants
that does not appear to be true
undocumented immigrants pay in to social
welfare programs from which they will
never get money back out they are
single-handedly holding on their backs
and shoulders multiple industries which
would collapse without them and most
importantly Donald Trump made the case
that economically undocumented
immigration is hurting the United States
because undocumented immigrants drive
wages down what is an amazing ruse about
that is that it's the corporation's
who want to pay lower wages that are the
ones benefiting
that and it's an unbelievably a brazen
act of misplaced ire to be mad at the
people coming here to work for a better
life than the corporations that take
advantage of them and choose to hire
undocumented immigrants without being
punished if we started enforcing
penalties on corporations that hire
undocumented immigrants you would solve
an overwhelming majority of the problem
if corporations weren't known to hire
undocumented immigrants then you
wouldn't have so many people getting
jobs and looking for jobs it would be a
problem that in great part would fix
itself then Trump talked about Americans
are dying from drugs that are coming
over the us-mexico border listen that
that is it's true that Americans are
dying from drugs but that's not coming
exclusively because of drugs coming over
the us-mexico border a lot of it is
marijuana first of all which nobody is
dying from and secondly according to the
DEA it's mostly being smuggled through
ports of entry
not through the parts of the border
which would be blocked with Trump's
border wall okay understand that most of
the drugs coming into the United States
from Mexico are coming hidden and
smuggled in vehicles and on persons
through the actual legitimate
on-the-record ports of entry meaning a
wall wouldn't do anything about it
Donald Trump is saying that thousands of
Americans are being killed by
undocumented immigrants yearly I was not
able to find data that supports that
although I'm open to having my mind
changed Trump insisting that it's a
humanitarian crisis well just saying
that doesn't actually make it so and
then Trump starting to move into the
appeal to emotion phase of his address
by saying women and children are the
biggest victims of undocumented
immigration that is true but women and
children are always the biggest victims
period all over the world from all sorts
of circumstances that doesn't justify a
wall between the u.s. and Mexico and it
doesn't prove that we have an
undocumented immigration crisis Donald
Trump deliberately conflated borders
purity and a 25 billion dollar wall or
35 billion dollar wall by the time it's
all said and done and what's really
important to understand there is that
it's untrue what Trump said that
Democrats aren't willing to fund border
security Democrats have actually been
willing to provide border security
funding not for the wall but for
technology and staffing in exchange for
reopening government and it's Mitch
McConnell and Donald Trump who have
refused to give any of those bills any
serious consideration it is untrue also
that everybody wanted a wall until Trump
was president and all of a sudden they
don't just because as a Democrat you
might have been willing years ago to
give Republicans some border fencing a
few miles of it in exchange for things
you wanted doesn't mean you're a
hypocrite because you now don't want a
25 30 or 35 billion dollar wall across
the entire border so big picture you
have a government that is not shut down
because of Democrats Trump shut it down
you have a president who has failed to
get what he wants and is now throwing a
literal temper tantrum which caused him
to commandeer television networks for
nine minutes plus the lead-up coverage
and the Pelosi Schumer follow-up speech
and the analysis of it for several hours
across multiple networks and most
importantly there is no crisis and at
least for now Pat there's no indication
that this address has really moved the
needle for Donald Trump
well we'll see I think this comes across
as effective propaganda honestly because
you have the president on his own turf
in the Oval Office delivering a speech
to the nation calling the immigration
situation a crisis
calling it an emergency I think that's
going to be effective so about you know
people just tuning in to their local
programming on CBS or NBC wanting to
watch their favorite show they may not
follow politics that closely they may
not stick around and hear the fact
checks here the response is given by
Pelosi closely and Schumer and you know
at this moment a majority or at least a
plurality of Americans blame Trump for
the shutdown I would not be surprised if
in the coming days we see that that's
flipped a little bit
those numbers may shift but you're
already starting to see even
conservative political analysts say it
looks like Trump is going to fail and
he's going to have to relent and allow
government to be reopened we will talk a
little bit more about that but in the
short term I don't see this helping
Donald Trump it came off is so not
credible it came off is so flaccid and
beta in every way and it also may have
been an illegal use of government
resources for Trump's campaign because
minutes before the speech the reelect
Trump campaign sent out an email asking
for donations on the basis of the
immigration crisis and previewing
Trump's speech and if you consider that
sort of part of Trump's campaign this
was a political speech used in this
manner to help his campaign and there
are possible ways in that that made have
even violated campaign finance law
although I wouldn't expect him to be
held accountable for it
we will follow it and see what the
impact is it is slowly happening Donald
Trump is successfully pushing out
everybody but Robert Muller who has some
say or oversight over the Trump Russia
investigation you'll remember that
Donald Trump fired FBI director James
Comey in order to interfere with
investigating his connections to Russia
that led to the appointment of special
counsel of a special prosecutor Robert
Muller Attorney General Jeff Sessions
recused himself because of his personal
conflicts of interest in having lied
about Russian contact and Donald Trump
eventually forced him out and put in
Matthew Whitaker someone actively
hostile to the Trump Russia probe then
Trump said he was going to replace
Matthew Whitaker with the permanent
selection of William Barr also someone
hostile to the Trump Russia probe but we
had rod Rosenstein the Deputy Attorney
General he was still there overseeing
the investigation for quite some time
breaking news this morning
rod Rosenstein is resigning according to
CBS News Rosen Stein will leave when
William bar the new Attorney General is
confirmed if indeed he gets confirmed
and there's every indication that he
will so let's cut through all the
sidebar issues here the issue is what
does this mean for the Trump Russia
probe which just had
it's grand-jury extended up to six
months as I told you on Monday I
completely understand why Rosenstein
would want out he's been treated
horribly by Trump he's been put in an
impossible position why not leave but he
has sort of been the last line of
defense here for Robert Muller
the one positive here is that now with a
democratic house if indeed Donald
Trump's henchmen find a way to shut down
the Trump Russia probe once rod
Rosenstein leaves and maybe not fire
Robert Muller but prevents him from
being able to really carry out his
investigative work
Democrats will call Muller into open
committee hearings in the house Intel
committee and a lot will come out which
I cannot imagine as to Donald Trump's
advantage now the counter to all of this
concern is that Rosenstein did
previously say to people that he would
not leave his position unless he was
satisfied and confident that leaving
wouldn't endanger the molar probe so a
more sort of charitable perspective on
this would be that Rosenstein is now
comfortable leaving because he's aware
that either the molar probe is almost
over or that if he leaves now it would
be very difficult to suppress what it is
that ultimately is going to come out
because the investigation is so advanced
in terms of its process so you know if
we're looking at the upside I will also
remind you that the molar probe is just
one angle in the criminal Trump
investigations you've got the Southern
District of New York you have multiple
attorneys general it's a very long list
and even successful obstruction of
robert muller if that's what ultimately
is going to happen here as a result of
Rosenstein being the last sort of a
pillar of defensive molar to fall allows
that to happen it's not actually clear
that at this point it would stop Trump's
legal trouble the genie does appear to
be out of the where do genies come from
Pat I don't even remodel the bottle yeah
the bottle yes so I think that this is
good news there at least there's no
evidence to suggest that it's bad news
yet because it's not like rod Rosenstein
was forced out I have to hope that he
knows what's going on and that Muller is
wrapping up the investigation soon so
nothing is put at risk he was one of
those
you buffers that we had remaining in the
Justice Department and I just don't see
him resigning without the assurance that
everything's gonna be protected that the
Trump Russian investigation would
continue on and that everything would be
able to continue you know I just don't
see it it's concerning but I tend to
agree that Rosenstein is not stupid
molars not stupid I assume that there is
a gameplan here and Rosenstein might be
leaving because Muller is getting close
to wrapping this up but he also might be
leaving because Muller is not done but
we've sort of surpassed the point of no
return in this investigation where what
Muller has is so damaging and
incontrovertible that any attempt to
shut it down at this point could
gloriously backfire we'll have to wait
and see but I want to hear from you what
do you think the consequences are of
Deputy Attorney General rod Rosen Stein
or resigning let me know on Twitter at D
Pakman make sure you're following the
show on Twitter too at david packard
show the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com big thank you today to
timothy Eggen burger timothy is today's
new david pakman show member of the day
joining more than 300 more than 300 new
members in january alone for the David
Pakman show
Irie I'm flattered I'm flabbergasted I
am something else with an F that's even
bigger and better than that at the
support that we are getting from folks
early in this 2019
Timothy just one of the new members of
the month and also Steven Kaplan is
today's sustaining member of the day
he's been with us nearly 5 years thanks
to even very much appreciate your
support become a member if you value
what we do if you're new here you don't
know if you value what we do no big deal
don't support us if you don't have the
money to support independent media shows
no problem I'm still doing the show for
you the show is for everybody but if you
have the means and you value the work
that we do and you understand the
importance of supporting media outlets
that reflect our values become a member
it's really cheap you can do it at WWN
pakman.com it's the right thing to do
you'll feel good about it I'll feel good
about it
Pat will feel better about it than you
can even imagine
and it'll be a good thing for everybody
so thanks to everybody who has already
supported us and who is planning to very
very soon okay it's time for hatred mail
if you've forgotten about hatred mail
quick reminder about hatred mail hey we
probably poison our entire family if
Trump told us to but remember it's not a
cult
patriot mail written by Patriots who
hate David Pakman because America and
because freedom ok this week's hatred
mail is going to need a little
interpretation if you are only listening
the read-along transcript that we are
putting up on the screen is important in
this particular week's episode let's
take a listen together
hey David punk man you can bash Trump
all you want
II won you're the loser those men who
don't feel manly and I'll include women
are the perverts of the world David
you're the biggest douche on YouTube you
brain-dead leftist David Pakman macron
that macaroni is a loser like you
I bet David brushes his teeth daily ha
ha loser you know uh guilty as charged
I admit I do brush my teeth not just
once but twice daily morning and night
and if something were to happen during
the day that warrants a third brushing
I'm not going to shy away from that that
I do admit but beyond that I am a little
confused by the idea that women who
don't feel manly are perverted because I
thought that this contingent thought
that it is the transgender individuals
who feel as though they actually are of
a different gender are the ones who are
the perverts according to them but now
this hatred is saying that women who
don't feel manly are perverted I thought
that's what the anti trans crowd wanted
Pat that women should not feel manly
they're contradicting themselves and
another point here you're upset because
Trump won and you just can't accept that
and that makes you a loser
well Emmanuel macron who the hate reott
also mentions is called by a loser by
the hate Rhea and yet he won his
election too so I'm just totally
confused on this one I think you're
pointing out that hatreds may not be
completely consistent and may have some
deeply held double standards I think
that that is not gonna come as a shock
to many people remember you can use the
coupon code hey tree at 40 to become a
member with a 40% discount when you use
the coupon code hey tree at 40 at join
pakman.com for a membership you get a
40% discount and many many many hatreds
cry they're so upset that their hate
reott ism has not prevented the david
pakman show from continuing to garner
support so that's available coupon code
hey tree at 40 ok due to a combination
of
you pity and lack of technical knowledge
I guess I would say pom anaphors own
lawyers have completely blown the door
open on Russian collusion and we now
have for the first time thanks to
Trump's Manta forts lawyers we have a
trump campaign official confirming their
intent to collude with Russia on the
2016 election and they actually did so
this story is so incredible in the
ignorance and stupidity that it exposes
that it almost stretches credulity that
this has even happened but it happened
and I'm going to explain it to you today
you'll remember that Donald Trump's
former campaign manager Paul Manafort
has been convicted of all sorts of
crimes this happened last year now his
lawyers are saying that he is really not
doing well physically or psychologically
in prison and that is now being brought
to a court's attention but what you may
remember is that he has done a lot of
bad things not only did he commit a
bunch of crimes for which he was
convicted he got himself into more
trouble because after making a
cooperation agreement with Robert
Mulder's prosecutors he lied even more
which is a violation of the plea
agreement his lawyers responded to that
claim as lawyers do but they messed up
big time because what man affords
lawyers tried to do was to put out a
filing that redacted four sections in
their filing and blacked them out and
we're actually putting up just one page
of this filing and people can see on
screen right now that the court filing
has a bunch of different lines that are
blacked out redacted so to speak except
they didn't do it correctly and even
though in the image we have up on the
screen a bunch of text is blacked out it
looks redacted this was done in such a
way that if you merely highlighted that
blacked out text copied it and then
pasted it into another document on your
computer in Microsoft Word or in WordPad
or notepad it pasted the full unredacted
text of what was covered up meant to be
covered up an incredible mistake and the
real blockbuster isn't the ignorant
lawyers
technically ignorant lawyers of Paul
Manafort it's the content of what they
tried to redact because the redacted
text says that Manafort lied to Muller
about meeting Konstantin Killam Nick
during the 2016 campaign specifically to
talk about the quote Ukraine peace plan
which is code for the Trump
administration's softening on US policy
towards Russia for their actions in
Ukraine Killam Nick is connected to
Russian intelligence so this is a
document not from Christopher Steele not
from Democratic operatives this is a
document from mana Ford's own attorneys
which confirms that the campaign
chairman of the Republican nominee for
president who eventually became the
president met with a Russian
intelligence agent I'm sorry
met with an individual connected to
Russian intelligence during the campaign
specifically to discuss what would
Republican policy be towards Russia and
Ukraine and to share polling data with
that same Russian individual the
document confirms collusion now remember
collusion in and of itself is not a
crime if Donald Trump knew that this was
going on that would be conspiracy and it
would potentially be obstruction of
justice depending on how Donald Trump
answered those questions in writing to
Robert Moeller and there's a whole bunch
of possible crimes that are connected to
what is admitted here in this faulty
redaction of pommes Anna Ford's document
remember how Russian actors ran those
targeted campaigns to try to influence
the election and one of the things they
did was target voters in specific parts
of the United States in certain ways and
in other parts of the United States in
other ways Killam Nick is a business
associate of Russian oligarch Oleg
Deripaska who has been tied into
influence campaigns and by the way the
Trump administration decided to lift
sanctions on Deripaska he's connected to
the guy manna fort was meeting with so
this has been blown wide open pat by
manna Ford's own law
yeah these people are criminals but
they're not criminal masterminds and
contrary to popular belief they do not
have the best people working for them if
you want to get away with a crime as
serious as colluding with a foreign
power to win an election you have to be
smart about it you have to outsmart the
FBI and make sure that you cover your
tracks it doesn't really look like they
did that in this case yes and of course
collusion again not in and of itself a
crime but the entire conspiracy to do
this and the cover-up is what may
contain a whole bunch of different
criminality and this certainly makes
that case far far stronger Trump's
campaign manager while campaign manager
Paul Manafort provided to the Russians
during the campaign remember data that
they then used to target voters in
specific States to help Donald Trump
defeat Hillary Clinton the only
remaining link that we would be looking
for now is that Trump knew this was
going on that would involve him in a
criminal conspiracy with Russia to seize
the presidency this didn't get the
attention it deserves because of
surprise surprise
Trump's bogus border wall immigration
crisis prime time address last night
maybe by design maybe not who really
knows but every single box is being
checked slowly but surely
take any any one of these issues take
any of the allegations that have
surfaced over time and what at first is
a question mark
slowly but surely becomes a definitive
piece of knowledge about what it is that
took place every single box being
checked
imagine what we will know in six months
or by the end of 2019 absolutely
stunning and unfortunately again because
of the timing of Trump's border wall
address last night this should have
gotten a lot more attention and there's
some complexity in it you have to
understand not only what was the court
filing but why is it relevant that
Manafort admitted to having lied to
Muller about his meetings with Killam
Nick and how kill him Nick is related
but you need to understand a bunch of
stuff it's much more interesting to
corpora me
to say Trump addressing the the country
about the border wall crisis way easier
probably better ratings for them as well
followed this story and other stories
from today's show on the David Pakman
show
Instagram page at David Pakman show and
while you're there follow me as well i'm
on instagram at david [ __ ] the david
pakman show at david pakman.com
[Music]
welcome back to the David Pakman show
it's great to be joined today by dr.
Natalie Marichal who is a senior
research analyst at ranking digital
rights where she studies the impact of
information and communication company's
business practices on human rights today
we're going to talk a little bit about
online advertising targeted advertising
maybe to start with I think a lot of
people in our audience who use the
Internet have a sense of what we mean by
targeted ads but what's a more general
overview of the different ways in which
targeted ads can exist thanks David so
when I was growing up and presumably
when you were growing up David we saw a
lot of advertising on TV in newspapers
and magazines on billboards and the way
that these ads were selected way that
brands decided what ad to place where
was based on the context in which it
would be seen so if you were driving
through an area that's near a shopping
mall you would see billboards for that
shopping mall or if you were in LA you
would see a lot of for your
consideration award show types of ads
billboard ads that you wouldn't see in
some other parts of the country for
example and so when the internet took
off the big internet companies and news
media organizations websites kind of
copied the same model at first let's say
okay well this is a story about golf so
the people who are reading it are
probably interested in golf so let's
show them some ads for golf clubs and so
on and then what happened gradually in
the late 90s and early 2000s is that a
bunch of company is starting with Google
realized that because the Internet is a
two-way communication channel they
actually knew a lot about the people who
were visiting their sites and what other
sites they had visited and who they were
and what they were interested in so that
they could match the ads not just to the
content that the person was seeking out
in that moment but to other interests
and character
mystics that the companies knew or
thought that they knew about the person
based on all the other data that they
had about them so that's why when you
look for something let's say a type of
shoe one day on one device that ads for
similar pairs of shoes maybe through
different vendors are gonna follow you
around the internet across different
browsers and different devices for any
number of days now there are there's a
wide spectrum of sort of opinion as to
whether this is a good thing a bad thing
an immoral thing an immoral thing which
would be a sort of different different
assessment but a common refrain that I
hear not only from people who are
working in the industry but also from
people who sort of claim to just be
objective analyzers of modern
advertising they say there's going to be
advertising people aren't willing to pay
for all content on the internet and the
way that they can pay for it without
paying for it with cash is by looking at
ads or being subjected to ads isn't
everybody better off if the ads are
targeted to the interests of the
individual that's the the kind of
talking point that is a common refrain
how would we start to or might we start
to break that apart into its component
pieces to consider whether it's actually
such a win-win right so that's a really
good point and I I think it's likely
that that advertising in some form is is
here to stay as you say there's somebody
has to pay for for content to be
produced and it does seem that the
market isn't going to support the full
cost of producing data or you know
things that you read things that you
watch think other kinds of entertainment
or information online at the same time
we have to think really carefully about
what it is they were giving up when
we're surrendering our privacy by
agreeing that anyone who has the
technical capacity to can track whatever
you do on the Internet combine that with
any other data sources that they can
acquire about you from credit card
companies banks your cell phone provider
your
Espie anywhere else and just say that
you can do whatever you want with it
that debt with that data as long as you
can make it happen right I think there
have to be some kind of limits so for
example there was a story yesterday that
came out in the verge about how several
cellphone companies in the US including
t-mobile were actually selling really
really detailed location data about
their customers to all kinds of data
aggregators and who were then able to
recreate exactly what people do day to
day where they go what they do when
they're there and create like these
whole patterns of life to use kind of a
spy jargon to figure out what
everybody's doing and then figure out
exactly how to insert specific ads into
that person's day in a way that feels
really creepy and invasive to a lot of
people so I think it's you have to think
carefully about what kind of data is
allowed to be collected about people in
what circumstances and and I think in
that case consent is really important
because most of this collection happens
without people even knowing about it
right so yeah along those lines
can you talk a little bit about the
difference between opting in and opting
out when it comes to this type of
information gathering right so when
you're opting in it means that by
default people can do can it can assume
that they are not being tracked unless a
notification comes up prominently and
says do you consent to being trapped for
this or do you or do you consent to
having this data about you collected in
this context and this is why we this is
why we the the website for example once
in what we might use it for and I think
for the most part that's completely fine
but then there's the assumption of opt
out which is that you have to assume
that you're being tracked at all times
and that maybe if you dig deep enough
you can find a setting to opt out of
that but a lot of times
that's only partially effective because
every time you come back to the site or
you reboot the app or what have you you
have to opt out again so it's it's one
of those things where if it become if
the companies who are tracking you are
trying so hard to do it without your
knowledge isn't that a little fishy well
let's explore that because you know I
think that we could have a reasonable
disagreement as to where the line should
be when it comes to what information
should or shouldn't be opt in opt out no
question that that's a legitimate
conversation but where I want to go with
you next is that this is not just about
products or services or web hosting or
sneakers or whatever the case may be we
saw how the same data that a sneaker
company can use to target people on
Facebook was used by foreign powers to
try to influence the 2016 election as
one example can you talk a little bit
about the non sort of innocuous let's
target clothing and grocery order
services to people and talk about the
ways in which authoritarianism in
different places around the world is
sort of fuelled by this technology
that's right so it's really important to
understand is that this digital
infrastructure that makes target
advertising possible is at its core an
infrastructure of influence right the
point of advertising is to influence
people to do something or not do
something and that same infrastructure
can be used just as easily to sell
sneakers as you say as it can to sell
white supremacy to propagate hate speech
to propagate disinformation and this can
be to store information like giving
incorrect facts to minority and
low-income voters to tell them that
Election Day is actually on Wednesday
rather than Tuesday we saw that
happening in the last election in the
u.s. it can be spreading lies about
entire ethnic groups and encouraging
people to harm them and that's something
that's been going on in Myanmar notably
via Facebook and it seems to me that
it's very difficult to to draw a really
clear consistent
line that is actually enforceable about
what the the benign or even positive
uses of this infrastructure is versus
what the what the harmful uses are and
to their credit companies like Facebook
and Google are trying very hard to draw
that line but as I think we're starting
to see the the line itself is impossible
to draw and enforcing it is even more
difficult yeah I mean I guess there's
sort of two directions we could go one
is would laws against the ways in which
the information has been used even be
effective if it's for example a foreign
power trying to influence an American
election because they're not even in the
United States we've seen even with some
of the indictments that have been handed
down in the Robert Moeller investigation
that they are of people who are not in
the US it's unclear whether they there's
even any mechanism to bring them to
justice so that's sort of question one
which is like a kind of a jurisdictional
question question two would be a
business regulatory question as to
whether what exactly is the mechanism by
which the government can say what can
and cannot be done down to this degree
feel free to address either or both of
those questions sure so I think you make
a really good point with this question
about jurisdiction and I think that's
what makes regulating a lot of things in
the Internet age incredibly difficult
and I think that's a really strong
reason of why the current efforts to to
draw this line as as well intentioned as
they are are probably not going to be
very successful as as hard as people are
working to make them work what I do
think is more likely to have an impact
is regulations like the European GDP are
or the California Privacy Act that's due
to come into force next year in 2020
that strictly regulate what kinds of
information companies and other entities
can collect in the first place how they
can be used when and how consent has to
be sought from the person whose
information
we're talking about and then maintaining
the right for for that person to find
out what information is held about them
have it corrected if it's wrong or even
asked for have it deleted and make it
very clear that people maintain the
right to control the information that
circulates about them throughout this
this infrastructure of influence that
that exists outside of our eyesight is
this politically viable in the sense not
from what it is that the end user would
prefer or tolerate but just sort of
pragmatically thinking about the
influence that the companies that are
doing this have on our elected officials
both Democratic and Republican you know
if there's anything I've learned that
past two years is to not make any not
make any guesses about what's going to
happen next in the world of American
politics fair enough no but I guess I
mean was so aside from predicting what
would happen just having an
understanding of the way in which
companies like Google and Facebook and
Apple are so much a part of the
conversation around how they should be
regulated without making any prediction
would you grant that the infrastructure
that's in place is one that is not
particularly favorable to our elected
officials merely making policy that
reflects the desire of the people and
that the lobbying dot-com industrial
complex is one that is is powerful I
think we would accept I mean I think I
think your analysis is is accurate for
sure but at the same time I think
there's a great danger here in giving up
the fight before we even start it yes
and just accepting certain things as
inevitable without actually trying to
change them yeah I mean I think if
anything what the last you know several
decades 200 years of activism have told
us is if you concede as inevitable
something you've definitely lost and if
you don't then at least it's a
conversation that you can fight over
that's right we've been speaking with
dr. Natalie Marichal who is a senior
research analyst at ranking digital
rights Natalie thank you so much for
talking to me today
about it my pleasure thanks for having
me the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
another day another direct connection
between krump and the Kremlin a visa via
the 2016 election this time it has to do
with that Russian lawyer Natalia vessel
and that's kaya also a story that did
not get the attention it deserved
yesterday because of Donald Trump's
bogus fake crisis immigration border
wall address to the nation
so let's reset remember that Trump Tower
meeting which at first supposedly didn't
happen then it happened but it was all
about adoptions then it happened and it
was about dirt on Hillary but they
didn't get the dirt and there was no
follow-up then we found out there was
follow-up but Trump knew nothing about
the meeting and most recently we heard
allegations that actually Trump did know
about the meeting all along before
during and after when it took place so
the news is all about Natalia Vessel
Mnet's kaya she is the Russian lawyer
who was part of that meeting sort of the
key player in that meeting she has now
been charged in a separate case not for
her involvement in that meeting she has
been charged because of a not not for
meeting with the Trump family members
and Kushner and whoever else offering
dirt on Hillary she was charged for an
unrelated case because of her
involvement with individuals tied to the
Kremlin and what's relevant about this
is that the charges detail how she has
connections to the Russian Kremlin and
indeed they are very close connections
that's another defense that we heard
from deniers many times which was okay
she's a Russian lawyer she offered dirt
on Hillary
she wasn't tied to Vladimir Putin or the
Kremlin are functioning in any way that
could be associated with being any kind
of official capacity
well she's now been charged federally in
the state of New York for trying to
thwart an earlier Justice Department
investigation into money laundering that
involved an influential Russian
businessman and his investment firm and
what we learned from those filings is
that vessel it's kaya is tied to a
company called prevas on holdings the
the owner of prevas on holdings is
dennis katsu and vessel Mnet's kaya's
involvement was specifically working
with senior russian
prosecutors to draft misleading
documents relating to the case
she's now believed to be back in Russia
of course this again raises the question
of who was she representing when she met
with the Trump campaign with Trump jr.
and Kushner and everybody else who was
in the room who was she representing
when she said I've got dirt on Hillary
that can help you defeat her at this
point it is impossible to believe that
she was merely a private lawyer you
would have to be willfully ignorant or
deliberately blind to not believe that
she was representing someone and there's
another really important element to this
a lot of the work that Natalia vessel
Mnet's kaya was doing was drafting
documents for cases related to money
laundering of Russian money through New
York City real estate that just so
happens to be exactly what we suspect
Donald Trump has been helping Russians
do for decades
my guess Pat is that Muller is all over
this and that if there are connections
between this and Trump or his campaign
that they will eventually be
incorporated into Moeller's
investigation which as I told you has
now been extended by potentially up to
six months but yet another one of those
boxes being checked yet another one of
the defense's we heard months ago
debunked and shown to be completely
baseless and even if it doesn't relate
directly to the Trump Russia scandal it
still hurts Natalia vessel nakaya's
credibility it's hard to believe that
she is on her own time out there
committing crimes money laundering all
these other financial crimes and yet
when she was working with or at least
speaking to members of the Trump
campaign she put that life of crime
aside and just wanted to do it
everything straight forward play by the
book
it doesn't make sense it's just not a
believable narrative big picture no
question about it now will she ever will
there be consequences for Natalia vessel
that's kaya we don't know again
reportedly she's back in Russia Russia
not surprisingly does not extradite to
the United States of America
so we will see what ultimately happens
but it is yet another baby step closer
to yes this is a Kremlin tied person who
was formally offering things of value to
Donald Trump detrimental to his opponent
once again the lies that we were told by
the trumpet defenders crumbling every
single day during my live coverage last
night of Donald Trump's propaganda fake
immigration crisis border wall prime
time national address I took a call from
a viewer who asked me when are we going
to hear from Republicans that the
shutdown has gone far enough
that government needs to be reopened
without funding for the wall and last
night I said if the shutdown starts to
stretch into February that will start to
impact people's ability to receive their
tax refunds if that becomes a question
mark that is going to light a fire under
the rear ends of some Republicans if the
TSA funding issues start to lead to
airport shutdowns and [ __ ] air travel
which of course relates to so many
different industries you will see at
least some Republicans say we have to
reopen government without border wall
funding and we're sort of starting to
see that now although it's really
important to remember that just because
a Republican says they want to reopen
government without funding for the
border wall we have to wait to see if
they actually vote to do so or if it's
even possible for them to vote to do so
and here's exactly what I mean the
people the three Republican senators who
are now saying we are looking we are
interested in reopening government
without border wall funding our
Republican senators lisa murkowski susan
collins and cory gardner they are saying
let's reopen the government even if we
don't have border wall funding secured
the fact that it is those three makes
perfect sense because susan collins is
up for reelection in 2020 she suffered
significantly because of her involvement
in the Brett Kavanaugh confirmation
fiasco she's at real risk from the
moderate Republican voters in Maine of
not being reelected in 2020 she now says
she sees no reason why the bills that
are ready to go and on which they've
achieved agreement should be
hostage to the debate over border
security Cory Gardner I've mentioned him
before he's a Republican in Colorado the
purple or sort of blueish state of
Colorado
he's also up for re-election in 2020 he
is one of the most at-risk Republican
senators for reelection
in 2020 he now says I think we should
pass a continuing resolution to get the
government back open and then you have
number three Lisa Murkowski who's not up
for reelection in 2020 but she's
generally one of the more moderate
Republicans in the Senate and she likes
to be seen as an independent thinker
whether or not she actually is one she
says we don't need to hold up six
departments simply to resolve border
security issues so as I've mentioned
before it's lovely it's delightful that
they are saying this but three
Republican votes is not really enough to
pass this bill in the Senate or any of
the bills that we're talking about so
this is a very safe thing that they can
do they can get the public relations
optics benefit of saying we want to end
the shutdown we don't need to have the
power we don't need to have the border
wall in place in order to do it but they
don't actually have the ability the
power to go against Trump and get
government open back up if Senate
Majority Leader Mitch McConnell won't
bring the bills to a vote it doesn't
matter whether Susan Collins would vote
to reopen government whether Cory
Gardner would vote to reopen government
because number one they're not getting a
vote and number two even with their vote
it wouldn't be enough to get government
reopened so I understand why they're
doing this after the Brett Kavanaugh
fiasco with Susan Collins I simply don't
trust her pad I mean she will say one
thing to appeal to the moderate voters
in Maine but then in the end she'll just
go along with the massive Republican
senators on so many issues yeah for now
we're definitely at a standstill but
ultimately I don't think it's gonna be
up to Murkowski Collins and Gardner if
the government reopens any time soon I
think that House Democrats of course
have no reason to give in I think Trump
is so stubborn that he's going to try to
keep this going and we're actually now I
think at serious risk of this going on
for months or even up to a year who
knows because there's just no incentive
to compromise on this one
well Donald Trump is being put into a
more and more difficult position
fortunately because he is going to at
some point maybe have to either relent
and let government get opened again
without border funding or he's going to
have to keep this thing going which
could become a court battle it could
cause political consequences that are
not good for Trump and Republicans in
2020 and as far as responsibility goes
we have new polling data which yes it
shows that 47 percent of voters blame
Trump for the shutdown and five percent
blame Republicans that's 52 total 33
percent blame Democrats the rest aren't
sure or our sort of split that's sort of
good news because it is Trump's fault so
it's good that a plurality understand
that but it is extraordinarily
disturbing that one-third of voters
think Democrats are to blame for a
shutdown that Trump promised on camera
and then subsequently did but I don't
know maybe 47% is better than it could
be and we should just be glad for that
but I think that there are a couple of
ways that this thing could go many of
which don't involve Trump getting money
for the wall the question increasingly
that is being discussed by Trump Trump's
inner circle is less and less how to
actually get the funding for the wall
but more and more how to get out of this
quagmire saving face and not appearing
to be the poor negotiator beta male
whatever terminology you want to apply
to it that Donald Trump actually is
given the fact that he had no clue what
on earth he was getting into by forcing
this shutdown will we know tomorrow will
we know next week will we know next
month I genuinely have no idea but the
longer it goes the more people that will
be incentivized to say Trump's really
screwing me over with this thing to the
extent they believe that Trump is at
fault I'm not gonna vote for him or
Republicans in 2020 and that's the
political risk that builds over time
we've got a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p you can call
any time of day here's a voicemail that
came in very very early this morning
let's take a listen to it
hi David I'm wondering if I could get
your opinion on some
thing do you think it would be prudent
for the Democrats to ask passing a
constitutional amendment which would
require all presidential candidates to
have previously held an elected position
want to know your opinion Thanks yeah
it's not a good idea so number one I
think it would be politically impossible
quite frankly to pass a constitutional
amendment that would codify that to be
President you not only have to be of a
certain age and born in a certain way
and the few requirements that are there
but that you also need to have held some
kind of elected position and there's a
few problems with it number one it
you're simply not going to get agreement
on that but it is such an amorphous
designation what counts right you then
get into the position of having to say
well okay senator counts governor
accounts a congressman or congresswoman
counts but what about the mayor of a
town or city well okay it should count
if it's mayor of New York City but it
shouldn't if it's a really small city
what about being elected as a city
councilor somewhere it's it's not a good
idea and I think we would be much better
off building a society in which you
don't need such a restriction people
realized why it's a terrible idea to
elect someone like Donald Trump without
having him be disqualified
constitutionally because he hasn't held
elected office I think that's the wrong
way forward I don't think it's really in
line with the ideas of what the United
States of America is so I think we're
way better off using voter turnout and
critical thinking and understandings of
history and economics and science and
everything else to come to the
conclusion that you've got to have
something pretty wrong with you or be a
bad person or be extraordinarily
ignorant to vote for someone like Donald
Trump I wouldn't do it via a
constitutional amendment I think it's a
bad idea I don't think it would work
either we've got a great bonus show for
you today we'll talk about how much the
health care industry spends on marketing
money which could be saved if we had a
different type of health care system we
will talk about a Los Angeles teachers
strike which could be just days away and
we will also talk about using genetic
genealogy to identify
unknown crime victims sometimes up to
decades after the incident has taken
place all of those stories and more on
today's bonus show I hope you'll join me
there by becoming a member or becoming a
patron thanks to the more than three
hundred three hundred new members in
January alone twenty nineteen off to an
amazing start and we will speak to you
on the world-famous bonus show in just a
couple of minutes
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]